[Musik]
venedig canal grande
wir sind am anfang einer fantastischen
reise
von venedig das von vergangenem
geprägtes sozusagen direkt in die
zukunft in china bis 21 jahren aus
[Musik]
unsere reise auf der seidenstraße folgt
den spuren und der mythos des
venezianischen händlers und abenteurers
marco polo
[Musik]
unsere reise führt uns in sieben folgen
von venedig nach istanbul
quer durch den südlichen kaukasus durch
zentralasien bis ins chinesische firmen
durch eine welt im umbruch
[Musik]
zahlreiche spuren in venedig zeugen von
seiner handels tradition mit asien
kamele pferde und schiffe haben schon
vor zwei jahrtausenden porzellan oder
seite hierher nach europa gebracht und
in der gegenrichtung sind begehrte
europäische produkte nach asien
verschickt worden
aber auch große gedanken philosophien
und religionen worden wie wir die
verschiedenen routen der seidenstraße
ausgetauscht
[Musik]
am kartell million stand einst der aus
der venezianischen händler familie polo
wissenschaftler streiten sich zwar hob
marco polo china erreicht habe
unbestritten aber restauration der hand
hier hinter diesen mauern gelebt haben
er hat wohl wie kein anderer dazu
beigetragen dass die seidenstraße zum
inbegriff für den jahrhundertealten
handels und kulturaustausch zwischen
asien und europa geworden ist
wir sind damals die menschen zu ihren
großen reisen aufgebrochen
wir besuchen das atelier des
kostümschneider von nicola
[Musik]
wie vieles in venedig auch dieses abteil
ihr lebt vor allem von geschäften die
mit der vergangenheit zu tun haben
[Musik]
guten tag peter willkommen
hier sind die kostüme von marco polo
eine auswahl die ich für dich
vorbereitet habe zum beispiel brokat
typisch spanisch führt mich durch seinen
ausstellungsraum
er hat seinerzeit die kostüme für einen
der bekanntesten marco polo filme
gefertigt
eigentlich hat es der firma einst selbst
schauspieler werden wollen jetzt kleider
den sieg ein
was mir fehlte war die möglichkeit die
materie anzufassen
die den gesang der seide zu fühlen das
geräusch der gewebe des tufts was mich
wirklich absolut angespornt hat war die
notwendigkeit das bedürfnis nach farbe
mit den händen etwas anzufassen
als schauspieler bei der vorführung und
war dies nur im kopf möglich so jedoch
sehe ich was dabei herauskommt
über 10.000 kleidungsstücke haben sich
in den letzten jahren in seinem atelier
angesammelt da sind zum beispiel kostüme
aus dem film casanova der ihr in venedig
gedreht wurde oder von opern der
kaufmann von venedig oder diese aus
elisabeth und all diese kostüme
repräsentieren mein leben
[Musik]
auch der papagallo für den weltberühmten
cirque du soleil wird in seinem atelier
gefertigt
[Musik]
ein papagallo der sich wie ein echter
vogel bewegt
wir starten
stefano nikon aufsuchten seine arbeit
stets sich in die figuren die er
gestaltet ihn zu denken
[Musik]
so war das auch der fall als er die
kostüme für marco polo angefertigt hat
[Musik]
ich glaube marco polo hat einen weg
entdeckt um die kulturellen beziehungen
erweitern zu können mehr als nur die
handels technisch venedig war die türe
zur welt für ganz europa mit der
entdeckung amerikas hat sich aber alles
geändert
die interessen aller länder die an
venedig früher für ihre
handelsbeziehungen gebraucht hatten
verlegten sich nun in die neue welt und
nach amerika weiß das gen spuren marco
polos folgen werden
er hat darum einen kleinen scherz für
mich vorbereitet und streift mir den von
ihm gefertigten leitungen marco polo
umhang über für die reise nämlich gern
entgegen denn oben hang aber lasse ich
hier
[Musik]
der markusplatz so kennt man beliebig
von den ansichtskarten
seit ein paar jahren übernehmen immer
mehr chinesen venezianischer geschäfte
bars oder restaurants an einem der
westlichen endpunkte der seidenstraße
werben nicht nur waren aus asien
gehandelt hier mischen mittlerweile
immer mehr menschen aus fernost in der
geschäftswelt mit zb die familie k
[Musik]
bootsausflug der chinesischen familie
auf den kanälen venedigs die
unternehmerin showdown mit dem
italienischen übernahmen laura stammt
aus wenn schuh bei shanghai sie ist 34
jahre alt und lebt seit 13 jahren in
venedig ihre brüder und ihre schwester
leben ebenfalls hier die zwölfjährige
tochter jessica und ihr zehnjähriger
bruder mit dem namen des stadtheiligen
alle wiese sind in venedig geboren
sie gehen beide in die öffentliche
schule zweite klasse mittelschule
5 dpa
doch laura findet die kinder seien hier
in der schule die nicht wie in china den
ganzen tag dauert zu wenig gefordert
viel zu wenig sie müssten nach china
gehen und mehr lernen
dann wären sie auch wichtiger konzern
beispiel mein sohn aus der schule legt
er den schultag hin und geht als erstes
zum fernseher
erst wenn er mit dem videospiel fertig
ist macht er die hausaufgaben so geht
das nicht erwiesen
[Musik]
wenn jessica erwachsen ist möchte die
mutter nicht dass sie einen italiener
heiratet einen italiener jetzt nach mir
geht
ich frage nicht die italiener seien gut
oder schlecht aber ich bevorzuge unsere
landsleute
es ist einfacher zusammen zu reden sich
kulturell zu verstehen mit einem
italiener braucht es mehr zeit meiner
meinung nach in der galerie fabry einer
seitengasse zum markusplatz besitzt die
34 jährige laura gleich drei geschäfte
samt häusern
eines ist ihre pizzeria sie sie bedeutet
ja alles wenn die arbeit ohne die
besitzer gemacht wird geht es nicht gut
klar auch die angestellten arbeiten
tüchtig aber es braucht immer ein
wachsames auge
der chef muss da sein sonst ändert sich
alles
sonst arbeiten die angestellten drei
tage in der woche und vier bleiben sie
zu hause
stimmt doch denn ich muss ja den lohn
bezahlen es ist ja nichts gratis
lauras jüngere schwester eva ist
geschäftsführerin von lauras accessoire
laden mit italienischen original
produkten die chinesische lösung zur
bewältigung der derzeitigen krise die
ganze familie arbeitet selber mit laura
schaut regelmäßig in ihre anderen
geschäfte rein
heute besucht sie diesen luxus kinder
kleiderladen den ihr jüngerer bruder
leon führt leon studiert sprachen in
venedig chinesisch japanisch englisch
und italienisch
ob all die teuren kinderartikel echt
oder gefälscht sind made in china
das wollen die kundinnen heute wissen
besonders kritisch sind chinesische
kunden
sie sehen in china das dort massenhaft
fälschungen gibt dann kommen sie hierher
und wollen wissen
sind die echt oder gefälscht riesige
kreuzfahrtschiffe spucken regelmäßig
tausende tagestouristen in venedig an
land die passagiere der monster schäfer
verstopfen die plätze und gassen der
lagunenstadt und sind gleichzeitig
willkommene kunden
[Musik]
wir machen uns auf seinen venezianer der
sichtbar der rialto-brücke mit seiner
sogenannten bank carla neben den
chinesischen händlern noch immer
behaupten kann
venezianische halt macht sind die
spezialität von alexandra massa longo
muscat in italy aber auch
preisgünstigere aus chinesischer
herstellung die herstellung stempel
zeigten unmissverständlich wurde masken
herkämen mein alessandro masala die hand
er zum teil auch mit chinesischer waren
was er denn persönlich von seinen
chinesischen konkurrenten hier in
venedig dreht sich alles ums geld
leute die wenig älter sind als ich haben
alles verkauft es genügte ihnen das geld
zu nehmen
die venezianische tradition ist ihnen
nicht wichtig die chinesen machen es
heute wie die italiener vor 50 jahren
als diese in die ganze welt reist und
weil es hier nichts gab
sie arbeiteten und legten das geld
beiseite so verläuft die entwicklung
weltweit
und wo bleiben denn die stärken die
besonderen eigenschaften die kraft der
italiener schöne frage heute wie es ist
nirgends auch die italiener haben
inzwischen fabriken in china und
bezahlen sie weniger und schaffen es mit
der chinesischen konkurrenz mitzuhalten
die italienische stärke deal ist in
italien
alexandra ist pessimistisch erscheint zu
wissen dass auch er dem stärker
werdenden druck aus fernost nicht
ausweichen kann
von diesem druck betroffen ist
mittlerweile sogar die insel murano mit
ihrer alteingesessenen glasbläser
tradition die brennöfen um das glas zu
schmelzen erreichen temperaturen bis
1400 gerade in der halle wird es bis 65
grad heiß
einer der wenigen verbliebenen
glaskünstler ist meist rot biologie bugs
[Musik]
früher waisenkind geworden fand er als
zehnjähriger nur arbeit auf murano
heute als 63-jähriger bin ich verliebt
in meine arbeit die ich jetzt schon seit
53 jahren mache
[Musik]
und barolo krebs denkt noch lange nicht
ans aufhören
[Musik]
solange mir gott gesundheit schenkt bis
dann werde ich weitermachen denn für
mich ist diese arbeit wie eine droge
ich könnte nicht ohne sein
[Musik]
die finanzpolizei des veneto hat allein
in den letzten drei jahren über eine
milliarde gefälschter oder
gesundheitsgefährdende artikel
beschlagnahmt auch auf murano mehr als
90 prozent davon stammen aus china
hin und wieder sind die in china
industriell hergestellten artikel leicht
am preis zu erkennen
was original murano glas wirklich kostet
zeigt uns paolo krebs in seinem
ausstellungsraum anhand seiner werke
eine derartige lampe kostet im laden
über 10.000 euro wann werden die
chinesen aus solcher werke fälschen
ich hoffe dass das nun geschieht denn
ich liebe die insel murano und diese
arbeit erst an der materie die mich
heute noch verrückten gehen denn es gibt
immer viel zu tun
wir verlassen venedig und folgen weitere
ein stück weit der spur von marc o'polo
richtung china zuerst nach istanbul an
den bosporus ans europäische tor zu
asien
in istanbul tauchen wir in eine
orientalische welt ein
europa und asien sind hier an der
engsten stelle des bosporus nur 700
meter voneinander entfernt
die landzunge und der hafen waren immer
schon ein chania der beiden kontinente
im austausch zwischen europa und asien
nimmt istanbul das einstige
konstantinopel seit jeher eine wichtige
stellung ein
[Musik]
es ist diese atmosphäre zwischen orient
und okzident welche touristen in
istanbul in ihren bann zieht
tausende berufspendler zieht lastwagen
überqueren tagtäglich die bosporusbrücke
von einem kontinent zum anfang
im großen basar der stadt wird seit
jahrhunderten geschäftet und gefeilscht
hier sind sowohl die geschichte des
handels spürbar wie auch dessen
veränderungen
schmuck porzellan zeiten charles
teppiche begehrtes souvenir artikel für
touristinnen und touristen werden
feilgeboten
aber auch antiquitäten der basis zu
weinen auch aufmarschgebiet der fans des
fußballclubs cannabis
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ein antiquitätenhändler begleitet mich
ein stück weit durch den basar ich
erkläre ihm was mich am traditionellen
an mechanischen uhren so sehr begeistert
weshalb es mich überrascht wenn man
sieht wie viele gefälschte schweizer
uhren hier auf dem wasser angeboten
werden
ja klar die kommen aus china meint der
junge verkäufer und kosten 150 euro das
stück
es sei den uhren zwar kaum anzusehen
aber es sei doch klar dass es sich hier
um fälschungen handle
[Musik]
mein nächster besuch gilt dem atelier
eines instrumentenbauers der begegnung
mit einer musik die in istanbul aus
allen ecken tönt und die für unsere
westlich geprägten ohren zum teil recht
fremd wirkt
[Musik]
die türkische volksmusikerin utah ist
sängerin und spielt die baglama ein
instrument das er von jetzt an fast
überall entlang der seidenstraße hören
werden
im atelier des instrumentenbauers sucht
sich youtube data einen neuen ball aber
aus und sie lässt sich dabei von
instrumenten machen beraten
die baglama so erklärt mir jeden tag
werde in der türkei hauptsächlich von
männern gespielt
ihr vater aber selbst auch ein musiker
habe als sie noch ein kleines mädchen
war sehr bestimmt die meinung vertreten
musik machen sei nicht nur männersache
und ja diese meinung ihr gegenüber auch
äußerst unsanft durchgesetzt
ich durfte also nicht nach draußen gehen
bevor ich nicht sechs stunden geübt
hatte an jedem tag hat mir mein vater
ein lied beigebracht er wollte dass ich
ihm das leder am abend vor spiel
er sagte mir nochmals ich müsse sechs
stunden üben ich habe dann
gezwungenermaßen geübt bis am abend als
es abend wurde spielt er nicht dieses
lied aber ich hatte tränen in den augen
und jammerte dass ich das nicht will
nichtsdestotrotz finde ich es sehr
wichtig dass die familie einem den weg
zeigt ob ich das später für meine
zukunft brauche oder will kann ich dann
immer noch selber entscheiden aber es
ist wichtig dass die familie einen den
weg zeigt die instrumente werden
traditionell gebaut das holz lässt josef
thomann zuerst sorgfältig austrocknen
erst danach wird es sanft für die
instrumente zubereitet das holz ist wie
eine frau wenn sie etwas von einer frau
wollen dann müssen sie zuerst ihre
sympathie gewinnen und ihr herz
erreichen wenn sie stattdessen lieber
manneskraft einsetzen dann wäre das wie
eine vergewaltigung
wenn sie die sympathie des holzes
gewinnen können erhalten sie auch den
gewünschten klang aus dem holz inmitten
der modernen geschäftswelt von istanbul
werk das atelier von josef dorn an wie
eine oase der vergangenheit
[Musik]
erstaunlich wie die türkische wirtschaft
wächst wie hier istanbul die bauten in
den himmel schießen
eine globalisierte welt mit
globalisierten führungskräften einen
dieser türkischen wirtschaftsführer
haben wir besucht den besitzer der yapi
kredi bank mustafa coach ist einer der
mächtigsten männer der türkei einen
interview termin zu bekommen ist fast
unmöglich
doch coach empfängt uns auch aus
sympathie für die schweiz
denn dort hat er das gymnasium besucht
im alpinum zuoz das habe ich gerade von
einem freund erhalten
das ist unser hockey team von 1980 bei
dem ich mit spielte coach der muslim
denkt durch und durch westlich die fünf
jahre in der schweiz haben ihn geprägt
in den 50er jahren produzierte sein
großvater den ersten kühlschrank und die
erste waschmaschine der türkei heute
arbeiten 85.000 menschen für coach bauen
jedes zweite auto der türkei und
betreiben die einzige ölraffinerie
der konzernsitz befindet sich auf der
asiatischen seite der türkei wenn
mustafaj aus dem fenster schaut sieht er
europa das finanzzentrum von istanbul
fast alles am lebensstil des patriarchen
ist westlich modern wenn er den bosporus
überqueren will nimmt er sein privates
motorboot
entschlossen drückt der 52-jährige den
gashebel und beschleunigt ein kurzer
rasante ritt von asien nach europa
coach wird zu einer
verwaltungsratssitzung er ist der
älteste von drei söhnen und präsident
der coach holding
zur konglomerat von coach gehört die
viertgrößte bank der türkei istanbul hat
sich zu einem bedeutenden finanzzentrum
der region entwickelt nichts steht
stärker für die industrialisierung der
modernen türkei als die familie coach
die yapi kredi bank ist die welt der
modernen türkei islamischer
fundamentalismus für coach keine gefahr
und das sagt coach denen die finden die
türkei passe nicht zu europa die türkei
ist sehr die westliche welt integriert
ob sie das mögen oder nicht
und in zukunft werden sie sehen dass
europa auf die türkei angewiesen ist wie
die türkei auf europa
wenn ich nicht mehr
die türkei habe 70 millionen menschen
ein riesiger markt für europa meint
coach in zeiten der krise wäre es falsch
zur türkei auf distanz zu gehen
ich glaube nicht dass europa mit dieser
mentalität in der nächsten zeit aus
seinen schulden chaos heraus kommt
mustafa coach ist vater von zwei
töchtern im alter von elf und 15 werden
seine töchter eines tages die firma
übernehmen
sie sind noch zu jung aber wenn sie es
können und wenn sie es wollen kann man
darüber nachdenken denn dann wäre das
ein historischer schritt für die familie
die frau am steuer
es wäre ein gutes signal für die zukunft
der frauen in der türkischen wirtschaft
und gesellschaft
wir verlassen das moderne istanbul und
begeben uns auf den asiatischen
kontinent
nach anatolien gewissermaßen ins
türkische hinterland in einem wiederum
ganz andere welt
[Musik]
weiter geht es mit dem zug
ist die türkei ein europäisches ort rein
asiatischen land ein asiatisches
allenfalls immer wieder wird gestritten
ob die türkei zu europa gehört die
wirtschaftlichen c von sie sprechen
dafür
gesellschaftliche allerdings so mein
eindruck ist der graben zwischen west-
europäischen werten und den
traditionellen werten gewesen türkischen
regionen noch sehr groß
[Musik]
stein
ein klein wenig gerinnen und mich diese
landschaft hier an jene im bündner
rheintal
wir sind viele stunden unterwegs und
immer wieder überraschen uns neue
passagiere
[Musik]
die 27-jährige t lag ja ja und ihre
18-jährige schwester saliha nur ekici
sie setzen schon seit stunden rettungs
im selben werk zu meiner überraschung
sind sie es die das gespräch den kontakt
mit uns gesucht haben und wir schließen
schließlich zusammen mit unserer
türkisch dolmetscherin den speisewagen
aufzusuchen
kelek ist mutter eines zehnjährigen
kindes in einem fairen kurs beschäftigt
sie sich mit psychologie sie versteht
sich als muslimin die selbstbewusst an
ihre zukunft baut traditionellem äußern
moderne in ihren ideen
ich denke nicht in schablonen niemals
ich bin offen
frau sein heißt zuerst einmal mutter
sein selbstlos ein selbstloser ist etwas
zu erreichen indem man teilt dazu muss
man arbeiten arbeiten heißt ich brauche
eine ausbildung für eine ausbildungs man
kämpfen
man muss daran glauben und wenn man all
dies führt gibt es nichts das man nicht
schaffen kann
das ist für mich kein persönlichkeits
vorbild sondern meine meinung aus
religiöser sicht es macht mich stolz das
kopftuch zu tragen
es ist kein hindernis für mich meine
ziele zu erreichen es genügt etwas
erreichen zu wollen
der wille zählt
sie leben als auch als frau in der
muslimischen welt kämpfen aber für diese
freiheiten natürlich alles hat seinen
platz absolut mein glaube ist meine
persönliche wahl nichts kann mich daran
hindern meinen glauben auszuüben
aber das heißt nicht dass ich meine
freiheit verlieren will
alles hat seine grenzen wenn es darauf
ankommt kann ich von meiner freiheit
opfern
und wenn es darauf ankommt opfere ich
von meinem glauben
es sind weniger die restriktiven
kleidervorschriften es offenbar mehr die
zugewiesene geschlechterrolle mit der
sich die leute ja ab und zu auch schwer
tut
[Musik]
wir nähern uns den bergen bei erzurum
die stadt und das tal hier liegen auf
rund 1900 metern über meer
[Musik]
am nächsten tag kurz nach sonnenaufgang
besuchen wir in der nähe von erzurum den
hof der familie tgt hier tauchen wir ein
in die bäuerliche welt anatoliens der
32-jährige jahr sind tikici und seine um
ein jahr ältere schwester zu legen hand
an
[Musik]
und wie an jedem tag alle bauern in
kleinendorf ort treiben ihre kühe zum
dorfausgang und von dort auf die weide
[Musik]
zum frühstück treffe ich die ganze
familie auch den vater
tikici er seit 83 meinte stolz als er
mich begrüßt jahrzehnte kita sohn von
loeb klagt darüber dass es den
türkischen kleinbauern zu sehen
schlechter gehe
in den läden der stadt werde voran
importiert das billigfleisch angeboten
seit die türkei die märkte gegenüber
europa geöffnet hat in der stadt bieten
die händler das fleisch viel billiger an
als mir das importiert ist und drücken
bei uns die preise gestern zum beispiel
kauften sie jedes kilo für 600 im
stadtzentrum verkaufen sie es für 1500
wir aus dem dorf kommen so nur schwer
über die runden
wir kaufen teuer ein und die eigenen
produkte können wir nur billig verkaufen
die familie möchte auch einiges von mir
erfahren
ich zeige ein kleines album mit bildern
aus meinem leben
dies ist meine tochter gianna hier sind
neben den bergen in der schweiz
meine fotos haben das eis gebrochen
jetzt stellt sich heraus dass löw u gar
nicht gewusst hat dass es menschen gibt
die kein türkisch sprechen und vor allem
auch solche die keine muslime sind und
ich erfahre dass der vater für den sohn
eine braut organisiert hat das gut kommt
zu meiner zukunft kann ich so viel sagen
so wie ich lebe so wird auch die person
die mich heiratet leben müssen
ich kann hier nicht mehr anbieten als
ich habe ich habe keine erwartungen vom
leben wie du lebst du stirbst du denke
ich deshalb gibt es keine probleme
und weil wir nun schon fast ein bisschen
freunde geworden sind denen mich die
beiden mit zum freitagsgebet in die
moschee nach erzurum
[Applaus]
in erzurum fällt uns auf dass frauen oft
nur in begleitung von männern oder mit
ihren kindern unterwegs sind
abdel karim ali ist imam in der moschee
ein wie sich herausstellen wird
strengeren strenggläubiger man hier
studiert der den koran
er erlaubt uns nicht gläubigen dem
freitagsgebet beizuwohnen und dort frei
zu filmen
lötscher hat sich für das freitagsgebet
besonders fein gemacht er rächt sich ein
wichtiges ritual jetzt noch die füße
der kleine verzierte silber schule
findet ein kleines prunkstück das an
einer kette zu einer feiertags kleidung
bauen
beinahe unsichtbar ocean auch ein paar
frauen doch den eingang in den hauptraum
der moschee dürfen sie aber nicht diese
riss den männern vorbehalten die frauen
dürfen den gebet nur abgeschirmt hinter
einem vorhang beiwohnen
[Musik]
das
immer mehr füllt sich die moschee mit
gläubigen wie man die sender zitiert aus
dem koran von einem gleichberechtigten
dialog der religionen helter im raum
nichts denn für ihn steht unverrückbar
fest es gebe nur eine wirkliche religion
den islam und es sei nicht wahr dass die
frauen im islam bevormundet werden
ich stimme dir nicht unsere religion
islam bietet den frauen den westen und
vergebung vollsten rahmen innerhalb
dieses rahmens können sie ohne einfluss
von außen druck zwang oder leiden
bequeme und das freie menschen ihre
gottesdienste erfüllen es gibt also kein
problem wir müssen dass moslems die
regeln und befehle der religion befolge
und dementsprechend leben
die religion kann sich nicht uns
anpassen
wir müssen uns der religion anpassen
vor unsere weite reise lädt mich ja im
ticket zum besuch einer archaischen
blutenden fährt der sportveranstaltung
ein zu einem schaafs polo fast überall
entlang der asiatischen seitenstraße
sind solche wettkämpfe zu sehen
[Musik]
zwei reiter mannschaften versuchen sich
gegenseitig ein schafsfell abzujagen und
dieses möglichst oft ins eigene tor ins
eigene lager zu bringen
[Musik]
von erzurum fahren die errichtung
schwarzes meer
eigentlich müsste diese seidenstraßen
route hiervon herz raum konsequent
ostwärts führer durch armenien aber die
türkei hat die grenze nach armenien
abgeregelt deshalb und fahren wir
armenien
[Musik]
die bergstrecke über den 2000 30 meter
hohen zigan abbas erinnert mich ein
wenig an landschaften in der schweiz nur
die minarette machen deutlich dass wir
uns hier in der türkei befinden
[Musik]
wir machen halt bei einem viehmarkt und
werden hier sehr freundlich empfangen
[Musik]
der wert deutlich wie sehr im vergleich
zur die wirtschaft in der schweiz die
bauern und viehzüchter hier auf sich
alleine gestellt sind
sie verkaufen ihre kuh ihre schafe nicht
einen gut organisierten großabnehmer
hier wird noch von mann zu mann
getauscht und gefallen
[Musik]
hierauf allen basaren in der türkei
stets wert und tee angeboten
[Musik]
während sich die bauern ihre höfe und
auf ihre felder zurückziehen waren wir
zur schwarzmeer stadt trabzon
voller eindrücke und gespannt auf unsere
weiteren begegnungen blicke ich ostwärts
richtung georgien wo wir dann mit
hochprozentigem feiern werden wo wir in
seiner residenz hoch über der altstadt
von tiflis von georgischen
spitzenpolitiker und milliardär bettina
iwanischwili empfangen werden
und wo wir das georgische höhlenkloster
war ziehen die mönche dort besuchen
dies alles und vieles mehr sehen sie in
unserer nächsten folge
[Applaus]
[Musik]